our next speaker or next panelist is
rosemary fea who's the executive
director of the Modern Language
Association MLA which is the
International scholarly society with
more than 30,000 members that supports
one of the most distinguished publishing
programs in the humanities her
responsibilities at the MLA include
being the general editor of MLA
publications including profession in the
MLA newsletter and sharing the program
committee for the annual convention
Rosemarie went to the MLA in 2002 from
the state university of new york buffalo
or she was a professor of Spanish and
chair of the Foreign the Department of
Modern Languages and literature's where
from where she is now on leave she is a
member and former vice president of the
board of directors of the National
Humanities Alliance and she also served
on the board of directors of the
American Council of learned societies
and is a co-convener of the coalition of
the academic work force rosemary has
published in the fields of contemporary
Latin American literature after Hispanic
studies feminist theory and cycle and
analytic criticism her put her book
publications include painting on the
page inter artistic approaches to modern
Hispanic txt novel lives the fictional
autobiographies of Guillermo Cabrera
Infante and Mario Vargas Llosa and
Isabella yendi today rosemary you have
the lapa hall and just be sure to be
close to the microphone thanks thank you
is this audible yes thank you Shannie
I'm really glad to be here even though
Spanish is in fact my field I did an
undergraduate bachelor's degree in
French so I feel I have some street cred
in the Y French matters as well as
representing all the languages that the
Modern Language Association teaches we
don't take the subway in New York we
have metrocards we take the train and we
I don't know that we aspire to be Paris
maybe the Upper East Side does buenos
itís maybe or maybe buenos itís aspires
to be us in any event let me start with
an anecdote a few years ago a
woman in an upstate town in New York one
several million dollars in the New York
State Lottery and she was interviewed
for a local radio program and asked what
she was going to do with the money well
she said I would pay off the mortgage
and pay her son's mortgage make repairs
to their houses buy new cars for herself
her husband and her son's family put
some money away for her granddaughters
education and her husband would probably
stop working all these projects still
left a sizable number of millions for
other endeavors so would she want to
travel as the radio interviewer no she
answered had she been to New York City
he asked no she answered wouldn't she
like to visit the city ask the
interviewer what for she replied this
was followed by a lengthy silence before
the conversation started up again the
interviewer thank the woman for her
participation on his radio program and
put a prompt end to the call so how does
one comment on the what for was the
woman's remarked a reflection of
unfathomable ignorance was it fear of
the unknown was it denial of the
possible pleasure or the application of
some utilitarian principle for the
interviewer wanting to visit New York
seemed natural and the woman's disregard
for the great metropolis left him
dumbstruck perhaps because it put into
question his own desires wishes in
values all unquantifiable emotions even
though he and the lottery winners spoke
the same language the clash of cultures
led to a momentary suspension of
communication explaining why French
matters can render one speechless as did
the what-for of the upstate new york
lottery winner you could of course
become quite loquacious if you were to
list the many world-changing historical
events sociological innovations
intellectual and cultural
accomplishments the artistic endeavors
the scientific discoveries and medical
breakthroughs that can be attributed to
France and French speakers and indeed I
could go down a long list but they'd be
very familiar I imagine
to be people in the room and the 50 some
watching remotely until the 20th century
French was the intellectual diplomatic
and artistic lingua franca of most
advanced countries as we just heard
French in in bed is embedded in the
linguistic fabric of English and French
is implanted in the American social
landscape from Maine to Louisiana so
where is French in the United States
today I'm happy to report that in
American colleges and universities
French continues to be the most studied
language after spanish between 2002 and
2006 enrollments in French grew by 2.2%
and from 2006 to 2009 French jumped
ahead by four point eight percent so you
hear French enrollments are down but in
fact on a nation level than the number
of enrollments in French have increased
in the proportions I just gave you the
study of languages other than English is
actively pursued by American students
between two thousand six and two
thousand nine enrollments and language
study rose by six point six percent on
American campuses there were
approximately 1 million four hundred
enrollments in languages other than
English in fall 2009 and French is still
a widely spoken language first language
in the United States if you go to the
MLA language map which you can see on
our homepage you can find the number of
speakers of French according to the u.s.
census in every state you can look at it
by zip code or by county and what you'll
find interestingly is obviously you know
what states are going to have a great
number of speakers of French those will
be the state's Louisiana states
bordering on our neighbor to the north
where French is the coal language of the
country official language but in the
United States there are approximately 1
million 325,000 speakers of French in
the home as a first language about one
in five people whom this
tracks speaks a language other than
English in the home this doesn't tell us
whether it's their native language
although in most cases it probably is so
one thing to remember when we ask why
French matters is it's an important
first language in the United States in
addition you can see when you go to the
language map the percentage of children
who speak French which gives you an idea
of the upcoming generations who will
continue to have French as a heritage or
a family language now those are some
pieces of good news but there are also
some issues that i need to bring to your
attention which we might classify as not
so good news even though French is the
number to language studied on us
campuses Spanish takes up about fifty
percent of the enrollments in languages
other than English French comes in
second but at about fourteen percent so
for those of us who wish there were more
students in languages other than Spanish
I know are there any Spanish that's in
the room i usually get a little
humiliation for that but even as a
Hispanic that our strength is in the
diversity of the languages we study
there's also been a drop in high school
studies and this is most alarming for
those of us who deal with language
education at the post-secondary level
the American Council of teachers of
foreign languages tracks enrollment in
secondary actually K through 12 and they
released a report on enrollments in
2007-8 and French takes up fourteen
percent of enrollments in high school
but Spanish takes up seventy-two percent
and I've heard it cited that the
students who actually come to college
you get admitted to college have closer
to ninety percent of spanish as their
language so you're not if you are
professors of french at the college
level you're not getting the number of
students ready to take your intermediate
advanced classes and your culture
history film classes literature classes
in the language so we've seen then
crease in French enrollments in high
school of about three point two percent
from between their two surveys two
thousand four five and two thousand
seven eight I think this is important to
remember for those of you as well who
can advocate for language study at the K
through 12 level we need to keep a
diversity of languages strong at that
level Americans are of course
notoriously monolingual you all know the
joke about what do you call a person who
speaks three languages and so on it's
also the United States is also called a
language cemetery because it's here
where the world was the joke you've
never heard the joke oh my god i I've
been indoors far too long what do you
call a person who speaks three languages
trilingual what do you call a person who
speaks two languages bilingual what do
you call a person who speaks one
language man there you thank you except
one in five Americans oh don't actually
classify as monolingual language
learning as we know is not a core
requirement in the American system of
education and yet in most industrialized
countries language learning is
compulsory starting in elementary school
the European Union considers language to
be inherent to the human species and
protects heritage heritage languages as
a human right educated Europeans are
expected to know their local or heritage
language the national language or
languages and one other international
language in 2010 the organization for
economic cooperation and development has
found us high school students aged 15
are outperformed in reading ability by
their peers in Hong Kong Singapore
Canada as well as those in Shanghai
China South Korea and Finland the
mediocre scores reached by US students
in reading literacy have been lamented
year after year by secretaries of
Education and presidential commissions
and yet there is currently no national
coordinated effort to focus resources on
expanding
language education at the K through 12
level and we know that knowing more than
one language increases your literacy in
your abilities cognitive abilities both
in your first language and in fact
create changes your brain structure at
heart French matters because all
languages matter they enrich our
cultural scientific and artistic
knowledge they surprise us they invade
our comfort zone and most importantly
they questioned us and in so doing
reveal the small space occupied by our
own sphere of knowledge remember the
anecdote the interviewers silence at the
what-for was perhaps due to his sudden
realization that New York City was
beyond the horizon or the reach of the
lottery winners needs interests or
desires maybe he knew he was projecting
his curiosity and interest on to the
woman he was interviewing his reaching
out to her interpolated him in return to
learn a language is to risk being
interpolated to lose one self-assurance
but it is also to know the thrill of
discovery the excitement of experiencing
something new the joyful satisfaction of
attainment all of these emotions in the
critical thinking that arise from the
shock of cultures inform us about the
others and ourselves that's their
far-reaching utility then after all the
competent use of a foreign language for
professional endeavors is something like
a high return on a long investment even
in the basement of a bank in France say
gomp the French might say thank
you